This video was made possible by honker impact third.
Thank you for signing up to our tour at the modern zoo of anime fans.
here You will be able to learn and observe different breeds of the species known as the anime fan
Please do not attempt to feed any anime fan you see as they live on a very strict diet of food
water, and trashy Isekai power fantasy shows
there's been lots of research of the type of anime fans that exists but
Documentation of modern fans are less common
As many well-known ones are now actually endangered or extinct, these include the commonly known
Casual, weeaboo and elitist, these primitive forms have now evolved into many different breeds
For example, now that the anime plague has become far more widely spread and accepted
it is harder to classify who is actually a casual anime fan and who is just a
Normal, healthy human thus we present the new classification model for the modern anime fan
We start with the life stylist
The life stylist has taken over as the modern image of anime fans and takes a more business casual approach towards anime many of these
are ex weeaboos or otaku that have now grown up and found this awful new thing called
A life, while they may have had countless hours to sink into anime when they are young
they may find these slight annoyances have cropped up like
Colleges or working to pay rent and try not to starve to death or god forbid a girlfriend
That means they have far less time for animes. So they need to optimize it. This means mostly watching things
They hear being discussed by friends or if they're really desperate might even resort to watching youtubers to give them recommendations
They are however still very knowledgeable about anime in its culture
So may end up spending more time discussing anime in person or online than actually watching it a trait also
reminiscent of the Memer it is argued whether a meme of really counts as an anime fan or not because there has yet to be
A recorded sighting of the species actually watching anime not including hentai, of course
however
You can find them in pretty much every facet of the anime community as it is theorized they are able to completely keep up to
Anime entirely through memes absorbing the surrounding memes for information in a process called. osmemesis
They are pretty easy to recognize as they have developed a unique language of communication through gifts
Shitposts and smug anime girls though. The fully mature of the species can be spotted at pretty much every convention wearing the fucking ahegao hoodies
It is unclear where the species normally resides in the real world
but rumors suggest that many of them are currently looking to buy property on our
Ana memes this brings us to the collectors
The collectors have spent way too much money on anime and they themselves
Cannot remember how they got in this position in life nor how to stop it
They are the Pokemon trainers of this world except instead of catching Pokemon. They catch waifu's under no circumstances
Should any of them be allowed within a ten-mile?
Perimeter of any device that can play Gacha games and it is documented that they would even probably invest in cryptocurrency
if it gave them a chance to get their waifu, despite their spending habits, they never plan to spend money it just kind of
happens once they think they reach a period of financial stability when they no longer feel the urge to spend is when there is a
perfectly timed summer event announcement with new limited edition
Swimsuit version waifus and the next thing they know they are googling how to sell their left
Kidney on the black market to make more money
It is the common misconception that collectors have a lot of disposable income
when in fact all they may possess a lot of is a lack of budgeting skills if we break down a standard monthly budget and
Show it to a collector $200 in food $700 in rent
$150 in utilities
$1500 on anime figurines and $2,000 on rerolls in fate gran order. They will look at this and wonder to themselves Wow
Am I really spending that much money on food and on that note
I think it's a perfect time to introduce the sponsor for today's educational video honkai impact third, honkai impact is..
oh for godsakes, of course you'd be here honkai impact is a free to play action mobile game
Yes, these graphics and gameplay you are seeing right now are really running on my phone and it is running smoothly as well
what starts as an action game with a simple attack dodge system quickly increases in depth when your lock more abilities
combos different characters training abilities with different characters while parrying dodging and air juggling and it evolves into an incredibly
Satisfying real-time combat system that will have you hooked you have a wide array of different
Waifus to unlock with their own unique fighting style with
customisable weapons and abilities to suit your playstyle as you play through the existing story mode or even use the coop features the game is
Constantly being updated with the most recent addition being the dorm feature
build a nice little house for your girls to rest in where they can train up in their spare time and generally just look absolutely
Adorable no. No. No, these aren't yours go. Get your own go get your own
If this sounds like your cup of tea
or if you just want to try it out to anyway then click on the link below to download it on either IOS
or Android and with that we can go back to our tour moving on next we have the hype beast
The hype beast has one goal in life to get hype ever since experiencing that first
Spine-tingling goosebump inducing feeling they live their life chasing that next high and will watch every anime fight
Sports anime and studio trigger show hoping to be able to reach that same high they once felt, understandably
They are mostly rooted in the shounen genre
And while they argue that the genre has become more respected critically to enjoy for older ages
This is just so they can hide the fact that they are all secretly man children nursing
Their inner sugar high twelve-year-old where everything was naturally hype similarly to hype beasts. We have cancers, cancers only care about one thing
Cute anime girls and every one of them is equipped with a built-in navigation
System that will cause them to gravitate towards the nearest source of moe unlike the rest of the community arguing over waifus and best girls
Cancers only believe in spreading love and acceptance for every girl every girl is deserving of love
Because every girl is Moei and if the answer is Moe
There can be no wrong answer
unless the answer is Nico studies have Shown that this
Overexposure to Moe has deteriorated the average specimen brain into a mindless mushy goop effects of which can be seen when they gather in one
Place dividing uncontrollably to form a massive unwanted lump that spreads infecting the surrounding area with fan boy roars of Moe love
Hence, the term cancer public sightings are rare. So many assume they are shut-ins who do not exercise in truth
They are merely hibernating conserving their energy to the next idol concert where they are able to release all
limiters doing a workout that breaks all known laws of physical human exertion within the space of a single aqua song and then we get
to the intellectual evolved from the now endangered
elitist the intellectual is on a journey to prove anime should be a deeply respected medium through nuanced analysis and critical discourse
But deep down they know they are just looking for a way to justify the countless hours
They have sunk into watching anime with no tangible achievement or merit to show for it
The biggest difference between them and old school elitists is that in this day and age anime is such a wide medium
So there is no longer widely accepted right taste in anime, and it is more about being able to provide a deeper well-informed
justifications for one's taste
however
While many intellectuals may seek to enlighten the uninformed casual some may use their newfound powers to put themselves up on a pedestal
perhaps they'll still unironically judge people by the number of entries on there my anime list like it's still
2008 proving that while there is no right taste in anime anymore
There is still definitely a wrong one though a close cousin to the intellectual
We have the animationtaku a new species that has risen very recently within the anime fandom
The animationtaku is a black hole for any and all knowledge about anime production
They can tell you the coffee girl who is working during production on the certain episode of anime and follows approximately
7,000 different animators on Twitter while they still technically enjoy anime
The anime itself is an insignificant factor when compared to the knowledge of the staff members who worked on it, though?
they will still experience a single involuntary orgasm at the sight of any impact frames an easy way to distinguish them is by the
Uncontrollable response of disgust when someone mentions they know about anime production because they watched Shiro Barco next up
We have the manga reader
these are a
mysterious species as we know they exist but they only really surfaced the moment an anime is announced then they all come out of the
Rocks and proclaim that they've been looking forward to this
Adaptation for forever only for the rest of the enemy community to wonder where the fuck they've been this entire time
A true manga reader doesn't have time for anime and has realized that reading manga is a far more
Efficient way to consume as much of it as possible
What makes them hard to distinguish is that they may look act and talk like anime fans
however
in reality
They would just watch one episode of an anime where they have read the source material and then pretend to everyone like they actually watch
The whole damn thing. That's right. Manga readers
we know. next we get to the Fujoshi
ONLY ONE MAN AT A TIME YOU DIRTY WEEBS, I repeat ONLY ONE MAN AT A TIME
Fujoshi are obsessed with men though have probably never interacted with one in their lifetime studies have shown they gain their lifeblood by shipping
Any two males who are within a 10 meter radius of each other?
Failure to observe any and all ships for an extended period of time will cause them to dissolve into a messy goop of gay porn
It is said that every female fan possesses a dormant Fujo gene
Even if they haven't activated it to become a full-blown fujoshi
The early effects of this gene can be seen when females grow an unhealthy addiction to mystic messenger finding out their heart skipped a beat
Seeing gifs of beautiful Asian boys almost kissing and fully completing their activation when they can sing the first verse of unravel by heart last
But not least we have the cosplayer
These are the breeds which have the largest exposure through pictures that have been spread online though. It is not commonly
Known that after a photoshoot is finished
They will disintegrate - back into their natural form of a pile of bobby pins and fabric tape while most humans live by a standard
7 day Gregorian calendar cosplays
will instead track their time in relation to how many days they have left until the next anime convention and thus exist in a perpetual
State of panic trying to figure out how they're gonna complete their next costume in time
recently cosplaying has evolved from just a side hobby to something people can actually do for their full-time job if you're a girl then all
you need to do is grow a small but dedicated following and you may be able to turn this into your full-time profession through a
combination of patreon streaming and selling prints and if you're a guy then all you need to do is
Yeah. Alright, good luck with that mate. This concludes our tour of the modern zoo of anime fans
Remember the anime craze has spread far further than we all imagined and knowledge is key to stopping this plague if you suspect that anyone
Amongst you may watch anime
Please inform your nearest police officer immediately so they can be quarantined and destroyed before they are able to contaminate anyone with their shit taste
Have a lovely day
Hey guys, so if you enjoyed that video
Thank you again to honkai impact 3rd for sponsoring this video if you want to give that a shot just click the link
In the dooblydoo and they'll bring you to whatever store your device is on and also thank you very much to robert Eyeborg
Basil patrick Madison Larkin and erryone else on patreon for helping to support me for this month. and making this video possible
I see a lot of you have been posting me pictures of your motherfucking tea mugs, which have now been posted out
so hopefully you guys are you enjoying your tea or
Coffee in these mugs and also you can watch some of my other videos
or follow me on Twitter or Instagram for some my other shenanigans
But aside from that until my next video I've been giguk and I will see you all next time